mich beschäftigt aktuell aber nicht die
Medizin sondern ein Tweet der Grünen
Bundestagsabgeordneten Kathrin
Henneberger besser formuliert er macht
mich wirklich fassungslos Henneberger
twitterte nämlich ich muss wirklich also
die groß ist besser und fordert damit
also ein Schrumpfen der Wirtschaft
lassen Sie es nicht einmal ganz deutlich
sagen die groß ist nicht besser sondern
asozial und es wirtschaftsfeindliche
Weltbild der Grünen was hier offenbart
wird muss endlich enden ich weiß nicht
wie es Ihnen zu Hause geht aber ich habe
für diese Kapitalismuskritik mit
Airports kein Verständnis mehr denn
meistens kommt diese Kritik ja exakt von
den Menschen die mehr auf Abruf haben
Menschen die Frau hennenberger die als
Bundestagsabgeordnete über 10.000 Euro
pro Monat verdient wer sich also
ausstellt ausgestattet mit einem hohen
Gehalt und einem sicheren Job hinstellt
und fordert die Welt sollte sich vom
wachstumsgetriebenen Geschäftsmodell
verabschieden der verhält sich nur
asozial ich muss das so halt sagen denn
für Menschen Entwicklungs- und
schwellenl ist es keine Alternative auf
weltweites Wachstum zu verzichten wenn
wir in Deutschland unsere Wirtschaft
Herunterfahren werden die Welt und
insbesondere die Entwicklungsländer
davon nicht profitieren im Gegenteil das
Weltwirtschaftswachstum und damit auch
die Entwicklung in diesen Ländern würde
gebremst werden und Menschen in
unvorstellbarer Armut enden und jetzt
würde ich gerne von Herrn Stock Wissen
Verzicht ist ja immer nett wenn es
Social Media Zeit ist oder man gönnt
sich mal doch nicht in einen Kaffee wenn
man genug hat aber was empfinden Sie
denn als Wirtschaftsjournalist bei dem
Statement von Frau Henneberger immerhin
sitzt die im Bundestag und ja regiert ja
mit also ich kann ihre Position gut
verstehen und auch gut nachvollziehen
und ich finde dieses diesen Tweet auch
nicht in Ordnung ich würde allerdings an
einer Stelle widersprechen ich glaube es
ist eben nicht asozial und es ist
durchaus möglich sich so zu äußern weil
wir genau das in einer in einer Debatte
in einer demokratischen Debatte brauchen
das auch diejenigen die nicht betroffen
sind trotzdem stell ziehen können also
es ist muss möglich sein dass jemand der
nicht hungert der reich ist der
wohlhabend ist was zum zur Armut oder
zum Wohlstand in dieser Welt sagt und
genau das hat sie gemacht deswegen meine
ich dass es in der demokratischen
Debatte ist das möglich inhaltlich finde
ich auch daneben sie sagen also
zusammengefasst es ist richtig dass sie
sich dazu äußern und ihre Meinung sagt
aber inhaltlich stimmen Sie nicht zu
dass die größte besser für die Welt ist
das ist sicherlich nicht besser für die
Welt und wir müssen wir brauchen
Wachstum um immer mehr Menschen auch
einfach ernähren zu können
Fortschritt beinhaltet einfach Wachstum
und wenn wir das nicht haben dann geht
es uns allen schlechter und deswegen das
ist eine These da würde ich niemals
zustimmen aber sie ist möglich natürlich
ist möglich Herr Herbst sie Sitz ja
eigentlich neben Frau Henneberger könnte
man ja so sagen das ist jetzt nur
bildlich gesprochen ich weiß dass sie
nicht nebeneinander im Bundestag sitzen
wenn ich sie ganz plump fragen darf wie
halten sie das denn eigentlich aus mit
den Grünen ja die FDP ist eine tolerante
Partei insofern halten wir es mit den
aus aber klar wir sind als
Bundestagsabgeordneter Verantwortung
dass wir Wohlstand steigern wenn man ja
mehr Wohlstand generieren und ohne
Wachstum kein Fortschritt und wenn wir
in andere Länder schauen die ja noch
unseren Wohlstand erreichen wollen kann
das Modell bestimmt nicht sein wir
schrumpfen wir werden Arm das wird nicht
funktionieren das diskutieren wir dann
nachher auch noch beim Thema Energie ich
glaube wir müssen einfach zeigen dass
unser wohlstandsmodell funktioniert dass
wir es auch nachhaltig gestalten das ist
ein Auftrag aber es geht nicht um
stromfunkverarmung und Verzicht aber
wenn sie sagen die FDP ist offen und
freiheitslieben und er trägt das dann
ist es nicht fast schon eine
Entschuldigung dafür dass Sie dann den
Wirtschaftskurs der Grünen ich muss
sagen auch Herr Habeck unser
Wirtschaftsminister macht ja jetzt
bislang nicht den besten Job oder würden
Sie da widersprechen naja wir helfen ihm
ein bisschen zwei Atomkraftwerke laufen
jetzt schon länger und er hat verstanden
dass Energien Lebenselixier für ein Land
ist und Wohlstand ohne preiswerte
bezahlbare Energie nicht funktioniert
auch nicht ohne zuverlässige
Energieversorgung und ich glaube das ist
ein bisschen unser Auftrag auch in
dieser Koalition dafür besorgen dass
auch die wirtschaftlichen Belange nicht
zu kurz kommen und nicht nur wünscht dir
was passiert oder ja irgendwelche grünen
wolkenkuckt sein wir sehen schon die
beiden FDP-Wirtschaftsminister als Herr
Habeck ich bin ganz froh dass Christian
Lindner auf dem Geld sitzt weil wenn das
nicht so wäre habe ich eine ungefähre
Vorstellung wo wir heute stehen würden
dann hätten wir das Problem was jetzt
Großbritannien hat eine noch galoppieren
schon zu den 200 Milliarden da haben
ganz viele gesagt wer soll das denn
zurückzahlen und wie asozial ist den
jüngeren gegenüber ja
Generationengerechtigkeit ist immer ein
Thema aber natürlich wenn die Wirtschaft
den Bach runter geht Zeit auch niemand
mehr Steuern das ist eine schwierige
Entscheidung zugegebenermaßen aber ich
glaube so dass wir gesagt und die Hilfen
nur für die Energiepreise und nicht für
irgendwelche anderen Wünsche das ist der
richtige loyal hinter ihrem
parteivorsitzen ich habe auch nichts
anderes erwartet habe wenn ich sie
einmal fragen darf wie sehen Sie das
denn wenn Sie den Tweet von der Dame
sehen haben wir über unsere Verhältnisse
gelebt
also das kommt darauf an wen wir unter
wir verstehen ich ich möchte jetzt
vielleicht direkt auch ein bisschen eine
Lanze für die Grünen brechen sitzt ja
niemand darf in den grünen der oder die
sich da jetzt sozusagen zum Verteidiger
auf zum Verteidiger nicht ich habe
durchaus auch Schwierigkeiten immer mehr
mit der Partei mit dem grünen sowohl in
Österreich als auch in Deutschland es
hat sich auch in der corona-politik
gezeigt und da bin ich auch sicher nicht
der einzige aber was sicher fakt ist
das Wort die grows ist jetzt überhaupt
nicht mein Vokabular aber wir haben
schon ein Problem übersetzen
schrumpfende Wirtschaft die Wirtschaft
an sich in Summe muss vielleicht nicht
schrumpfen sie muss sich fairer
verteilen also die Wirtschaft muss fair
werden im globalen Sinn also es muss
eine faire und eine Chancengleichheit
und auch eine Ressource eine faire
Ressourcenverteilung da sein damit eben
auch Menschen aus jetzt nachteiligen
benachteiligten Regionen oder auch die
Biodiversität des Planeten genau das
Schlimme wenn wir die groß haben leiden
Gardine entwickeln denn wir haben ja
hier wir haben sprechen wir haben so was
wie Oligopole riesige Konzerne die sich
in den verschiedenen Sparten alles unter
den Nagel reißen und dann die ganze Welt
damit beglücken und da werden dann auch
kleinbauerinnen und Kleinbauern in
Südamerika in Afrika in in Asien und
anderen Ländern werden immer mehr unter
Vertrag gestellt teilweise verlieren die
auch ihr Land sind dann nur mehr
Erntehelfer wir haben eine Agroindustrie
die mit ihren hochleistungszüchtungen
die ganze Welt
für den Klimawandel
Klimawandel ist nicht das einzige Thema
der Klimawandel ist ja nur ein Aspekt
eines großen umweltwandels das große
Thema ist die Biodiversität die
schwindet unsere Ökosysteme schwinden
hinweg die Lebensräume der Menschen und
wir brauchen eine Wirtschaft die wieder
mehr auch auf das etwas dezentraler
funktioniert und und wo dann auch
Menschen also wenn wir jetzt sagen wir
sind die großen Heilsbringer wenn wir
mit unseren gentechnisch veränderten
Saatgut nach Südamerika nach Paprika
nach Asien gehen und glauben dass das
die Probleme dort bekämpft dann muss ich
sagen die Realität sieht anders aus was
dort gebraucht würde sind da reden sie
jetzt über fairere Bedingungen wir reden
aber auch für eine
etwas ein mehr Autonomie mehr Subsistenz
mehr wieder dort angepasste Sorten in
der Landwirtschaft zum Beispiel das
wieder dort das Know-how wieder wachsen
kann das ist ja auch dort vorhanden ja
dass wir nicht überall mit unseren
großen Konzernen alles okkupieren
sozusagen also von dem her die grows
würde ich in einem positiven Sinn so
verstehen dass man sagt es muss diese
geballte wirtschaftliche Macht in den
Händen großer Konzerne das muss man dazu
tatsächlich drei Mal noch mal für Sie
auch was die auch bedeutet das bedeutet
wie Sie es wahrscheinlich dann auch
wollen zum Beispiel Konzerne zerschlagen
oder auch nicht mehr mit dem Auto fahren
nicht mehr fliegen Verzicht üben das ist
ja auch sehr viel die groß was schönes
also ich verzichte gerne mal auf Social
Media Zeit da übe ich mich in Verzicht
aber ich kann es auch und habe auch
sonst alle Möglichkeiten dementsprechend
sie fordern wenn Sie das fordernd ist
natürlich eine legitime these aber dann
fordern Sie Verzicht verzichten sie denn
schon auf Autofahren
ist jetzt nicht nicht mein anziehen aber
wie gesagt diese diese globale
Gerechtigkeit kann nur hergestellt
werden wenn nicht diese gesamte
wirtschaftspolitische Macht in den
Händen des Westens unter
Anführungszeichen ist und es zu
ausbeutungsverhältnissen in anderen
Regionen kommt und Verzicht also ich
will mich nicht ich mache zum Beispiel
steigt zum Beispiel nicht ins Flugzeug
aus ökologischen Gründen schon längere
Zeit nicht mehr und komme damit auch
sehr gut klar also ich komme auch
trotzdem innerhalb Europas überall hin
ohne den Erdboden zu verlassen
ohne Probleme und also das ist jetzt
vielleicht ein Klassiker aber zum
Beispiel der Verzicht auf Fleisch ist
schon auch ein Aspekt oder dass man auf
die Quelle des Fleisches mehr achtet
wenn man Fleisch konsumiert das ist
wirklich ökologisch produziert ist denn
da spielt ja auch die Tierethik es ist
ja alles miteinander verwoben die
Tierethik eine wichtige Rolle dass man
eben auch keine ausbeutungsstrukturen in
der Tierhaltung unterstützen möchte und
solche Dinge glaube ich das sind keine
großen verzichthemen sondern das ist
eine Frage wo man die Gewichtung legt
Genuss kann zum Beispiel auch dann
stattfinden wenn man sehr viel Gemüse
ist Gemüse Vielfalt am Teller ist was
wundervolles oder eben andere
pflanzliche Produkte oder vegetarische
Produkte es muss es nicht Unmengen von
Fleisch und Wurst sein das ist für mich
persönlich kein Verzicht bevor wir den
Werbung verzichten
mit dem Flugzeug ist für mich kein
Verzicht weil ich habe Alternativen die
mich ebenso glücklich machen dann
wir fragen doch mal Herrn Specht worauf
verzichten sie denn Herr Specht also
darauf nicht ich verzichte momentan am
liebsten aufs Fliegen aber nicht aus
ökologischen Gründen sondern weil es
einfach so kompliziert geworden ist dass
man da gar nicht mehr richtig ankommt
mit dem Bahn fahren ist allerdings auch
ziemlich schwierig aber was ich sagen
ich sehe es natürlich ein bisschen
anders ich glaube wir haben eine
Technikfeindlichkeit entwickelt und wir
haben den Eindruck es wäre die Welt
immer schlechter geworden in den letzten
Jahrzehnten das Gegenteil ist der Fall
die Armut ist bekämpft worden in auf dem
gesamten Globus gerade weil wir den
technischen Fortschritt hatten die
Grünen haben in den 80er Jahren nein
schon in den 70er Jahren dass Mantra
ausgegeben das Gentechnik prinzipiell
schlecht wäre ich möchte nur mal kurz
daran erinnern wieder auf die Medizin
als Beispiel jeder kennt das Diabetes
wie behandeln wir das mit Insulin das
war noch Schweine Insulin man musste
schweinegewebe nehmen um dieses Insulin
zu bekommen erst die Gentechnik durch
die Firma höchst damals hat es möglich
gemacht dass man das auch gen technisch
durch Bakterien herstellen kann eine
sensationelle Geschichte die die den
Prozess wesentlich reiner gemacht hat
auch aus tieretischer Sicht im übrigen
das ist in Deutschland nicht möglich
gewesen sondern musste dann im Ausland
gemacht worden werden also was ich sagen
möchte ist ich glaube wir sehen zu
schwarz wir müssen deutlich positiver an
dieser herangehen und nur die gerade die
Technik allerdings natürlich klug
eingesetzt wir müssen schon einige
Veränderungen machen da bin ich bei
ihnen aber die klug eingesetzte auch
ökologisch klug eingesetzte Technik die
kann uns weiterbringen nicht ein die
groß angepasste Technik wird